>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Fenella France: So
welcome, everybody.
Thank you for coming, today.
I am Fenella France.
I'm the chief of the Preservation
Research and Testing Division.
And along with Preservation
Reformatting, we're delighted
to invite our speaker for
the talk's lecture today.
Olivia Dill received her BA
in physics and art history
for UC Berkley in 2014, and she's
currently a project specialist
for the UC Berkley IRENE Project.
For those of you who don't know,
IRENE is Image, Reconstruct,
Erase Noise, et cetera, not someone
who sits in the back of the lab.
And she's working on maintaining
and operating the workstation,
digitizing 3000 wax
cylinders in the Hearst Museum
of Anthropology collections.
She designed the mass digitization
workflow for the project
and developed and updated much of
the acquisition code and software.
We'd like to actually say
thanks to NEH and NSF grant
for documenting endangered
languages.
And her talk today is Analyzing
Images to Digitize Sound
on Historic Audio Recordings.
Olivia, please.
[ Applause ]
>> Olivia Dill: Hi and thank
you for having me here today
and thank you all for coming.
My name as was said is
Olivia Dill and I work
for the UC Berkeley Library.
I'm running a lab that's using
optical scanning to digitize audio
on wax cylinder sound recordings.
Optical scanning is a method
that's developing now and is used
to digitize the content on early
mechanical sound recordings using
images of the media rather than
contact with their surfaces.
The method may be familiar
to many of you here
as the technology has been developed
with a strong collaboration
between the Library of Congress
and Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratory over the last decade.
But today, I'm here to
discuss its latest application
which is the project that I work on.
Our project whose title
you'll see here at the top
of the screen is a three-year
project funded by a grant
from the National Science
Foundation and National Endowment
for the Humanities Documenting
Endangered Languages Program.
Our goal is over three years
to create digital versions
of the audio record on
around 3000 wax cylinders
in the Phoebe A. Hearst Museum
of Anthropology collection using
this optical scanning technique.
And today, I'll be walking you
through how the optical
scanning method works in general,
how we're applying it for this
project and the future directions
and implications that we
see this project taking.
So the method that we're using
was developed with the aim
of increasing access to media
from the early history
of sound recording.
Sound was first recorded
in 1859 and the materials
on which sound was recorded around
this time were oftentimes delicate
and have only become more delicate
in the year since their recording.
The optical scanning technology
is non-contact and image-based,
so it allows us to play back
and preserve these historic sound
recordings in different formats
and in different states
of stability.
The method has been used to play
back some of the earliest recordings
in history on collections
of different media
across the country and abroad.
And my project, the mass
digitization of cylinders
in the Hearst Museum collection,
is just the latest application,
the newest iteration
of this technique.
So a fundamental very
basic place to start is
with the question what
is a wax cylinder?
But in order to really answer that,
we have to take a step backwards
and answer the even more fundamental
question of what is sound.
Sound is a motion-based effect.
It is the result of
particles compressing
and rarefacting repeatedly as
they travel through some medium.
And this creates oscillating
areas of high and low pressure.
Two of the main properties that
we use to perceive a sound--
to perceive sound are a
sound wave's volume and pitch
and how those two properties
change over time.
The amplitude of oscillation
translates to the volume
of the sound and the frequency at
which particles oscillate translates
to the perceived pitch
or tone of the sound.
And the feat of these of these
early sound recordings is
to create a retrievable trace
of that amplitude and frequency
of oscillations and
how they're changing
in time on some physical medium.
So a wax cylinder is
exactly what it sounds like.
It's a cylinder that's
made out of wax.
They're typically about
four to six inches tall
and two inches in diameter.
The wax itself is hard but malleable
enough to be easily scraped away.
And so to record sound onto a wax
cylinder, a small needle or a cutter
on a machine called a phonograph
is inserted into the wax
and the cylinder is spun
underneath the cutter.
The cutter drags along the surface
of the cylinder, removing wax
and leaving a groove behind it.
Every time the cylinder completes
one revolution, the cutter is forced
by the recording machine to move
over by some small set amount
and this creates one
long continuous spiral
down the length of
the entire cylinder.
To actually record audio, a speaker
speaks into a horn on a phonograph
that collects the sound waves
being produced and transfer thems--
transfers them through a coupling
mechanism in the recording device
to the cutter, and this drives
the cutter to bob up and down,
changing the depth of the
groove that it's cutting.
To play back the audio,
you just carry
out this process in the reverse.
A playback stylus on the phonograph
is coupled to the horn instead
of the cutter and the stylus
is placed in the grooves
so that it rests along
the groove bottom.
And then the cylinder is rotated.
And as the cylinder rotates,
the stylus drags along the
groove bottom, retracing the path
of the original cutter, recreating
its vertical oscillation,
and with that vertical motion, the
original audio that was recorded.
And so, then that means,
with that physical intuition,
we can understand that the
physical trace that sound leaves
on the surface of the wax cylinder
which is the link to the information
that we want to recover from it is
the shape of the cylinder's surface,
and specifically the shape of the--
the shape of the groove
and the changing height
of the groove bottom.
The relevant scale on which this
occurs is micrometers or microns.
One micron is one one-thousandth
of a millimeter.
For scale, the average human hair
is going to be around 50 microns.
The needles on the recording
devices and the grooves
that they cut are typically
a few hundreds microns wide
and their vertical
oscillation is going to be
around 10 microns from
top to bottom.
So the vertical displacement
that creates audio is small.
It's about one-fifth of a
human hair but it's measurable.
This technology was
first invented in 1877.
And by 1890, a device called
the Edison phonograph had become
commercially available
in a reasonably easy
to operate, transportable form.
Anthropologists, linguists,
ethnographers
and other academics
studying language
and oration saw the
phonograph as an opportunity
to more efficiently capture
the songs and the languages
that they had previously been
transcribing all by hand.
So they took to the new technology
and they quickly incorporated
it into their research.
And during the years of the
phonographs, initial popularity,
many scholars across the US
and around the world engaged
in dedicated campaigns where
they went out into field,
engaged with indigenous groups
to record their languages producing
tens of thousands of recordings.
And the collection that I'm
working with for the Hearst Museum
of Anthropology is the result of one
of these field recording campaigns.
The cylinders in the Hearst Museum
of Anthropology collection were
collected by Alfred Kroeber
who was the founded of-- founder
of the UC Berkley Anthropology
Department.
He and his students
collected them as part
of an extensive ethnographic survey
of Native Californian cultures.
Over 39 years, starting
in 1900, Kroeber
and his students traveled
throughout California
and collected 2746 separate
recordings of Native Californians.
The content of these
recordings varies.
They contain both song and
speech in 78 different languages.
They record things like dance
songs, descriptions of activities,
medicinal songs, myths,
creation stories, histories,
among other important things.
These anthropologists who collected
these recordings envisioned
themselves as building a
research resource for linguists
and anthropologists
and others in academia,
and the collection
certainly still is that today.
But today, it has also become
valuable to community members
who are oftentimes
contemporary members of the tribes
that are recorded, and in
many cases, direct descendants
of the actual people
recorded on the cylinders.
Many of the languages recorded
have transformed or fallen
out of widespread spoken
use since recording,
so the collection has become a
valuable resource for language
and cultural revitalization
projects.
Until now, collection engagement
has been through transfers made
in the 80s onto reel to reel
tape using the traditional method
of playback which is
the hard stylus.
But these transfers do not
include broken cylinders.
The quality of the audio often makes
content difficult to understand.
And most have not been
converted to digital formats.
So the logistics of actually
getting them to the people
that are interested in them are
difficult, time-consuming and costly
for both the patron
and for the museum.
The cylinders themselves, in many
cases, have been broken or cracked
and have become prone-- more
prone to breaking with age.
And the surface of the cylinders is
being eaten away by a type of mold
that thrives on wax and lives in
the linings of the original housings
in which the cylinders were stored.
So the overall picture
that we're looking at is,
that the Hearst Museum collection
is unique, it's invaluable both
to community members
and to scholars.
But the results of previous
transfers are difficult
to create access to, and any method
of creating new transfers must
be able to cope with artifacts
in delicate and decaying condition,
and that's where the
optical method comes in.
The optical method uses a
physics-based understanding
of the mechanics of sound
and recording devices coupled
with a physicist training and making
and interpreting precision
measurements of observables,
to measure the physical traces
of the recording process
and recreate the audio
that made them.
The optical method asks
two questions of materials.
First, can we measure the surface
of the media without touching it
in a way that allows us to create
a sufficiently detailed image
of that surface?
And second, can we display that
image in a way that allows us
to systematically analyze it,
recreate the playback process
and recover the sound
from the recording?
Digitizing recordings,
through this process,
answers a lot of the problems
that come up in dealing
with these collections
of sound recordings.
The only physical demand on
objects is that they be maneuvered
and have light shown on them,
so this opens up access
to delicate materials.
The method is computer-based which
allows the process to be automated
and carried out systematically
for many recordings.
And the method works in images
and more over detailed images
which provides information
about the condition of objects
that can't be had simply
by playing them back.
And also, using this method
eliminates the need to maintain
and operate outdated
recording devices.
In the Hearst Museum case,
there are 3000 cylinders
to be digitized approximately,
with funding from the NSF and NEH
that was scheduled to
last for three years.
In assessing how plausible
the optical method is
for our collection, we considered
relevant dimensions of cylinders,
what measures we would
need and how precisely
and quickly the performance
speculations--
or specifications rather
of available measuring devices would
allow us to make those measurements.
For wax cylinders, we
use a confocal probe
that collects height measurements
along the line on the surface.
And pilot studies for this project
showed us that we could work
within the needs of that
prove and collect data
with sufficient accuracy to
give us the images that we need.
Furthermore, the rate at which the
probe could collect measurements was
high enough that the time taken to
scan each cylinder would allow us
to scan the requisite
six cylinders per day
to remain on our project timeline.
And so, given the condition of the
cylinders, the number that we have
to work with, the technical
capabilities
of available measuring devices and
the desired format specifications
for the final audio, the optical
method was the method that we chose
to digitize our collection.
So in order to actually apply this,
we developed and applied a workflow
to systemically work through
the cylinders in the collection.
For each of the 3000
cylinders to be digitized,
we need to work clockwise
around this graphic.
First, we make many hundreds
of thousands of measurements
of the height of the
surface of the cylinder.
Then we stitch them together
to make a high-resolution
three-dimensional map
at the surface.
That map is then loaded into a
piece of software that displays it,
calculates how the stylus would have
moved over the surface and then uses
that information to
create an audio waveform.
The audio is written out
to a separate digital file,
the map itself can be archived
and reprocessed later as needed.
So to actually implement this,
the first half of the process is
to acquire the necessary data.
For wax cylinders, we use a
confocal microscope or probe.
It's a tool that collects
height measurements along a line
on a surface, when that surface
is within a set focal distance.
The probe-- How the probe
works is it shines white light
through a series of lenses, and
those lenses break the white light
into its constituent
wavelengths, such that each color
of light focuses at
a different height.
Then when you place a surface within
that focal range of the probe,
the surface is going to be at the
height where one color isn't focused
and the rest are out of focus.
And so the color that's in
focus reflects directly up back
where it came from and
the rest scatter of.
And so the probe also collects
the light that's reflected
from the surface, analyzes it
to tell what color is in focus.
And from that, can measure the
distance to the surface in front
of it to an accuracy of
around 75 nanometers,
and that accuracy is more than
enough to resolve the shapes
that are relevant on the
wax cylinder surface.
The probe does this
shining and analyzing
at 180 points along a
line, across the surface
and outputs a list
of 180 height values.
If you take this probe and you
point it at a wax cylinder surface,
you'll see the image
on the upper right.
And what you're seeing is
this very regular pattern
of peaks and valleys.
And the way to read this is that the
probe is shining a light on a line
that lands on the surface of
the cylinder across the groove.
As the groove winds around cylinder,
it intersects that line many times.
And so the many valleys are in many
sections at the same groove bottom
and the peaks are the uncut
highest surface of the cylinder.
To actually do a wax cylinder
scan, the wax cylinder is loaded
on a rod that's attached to
a rotating motor so the rod
and the cylinder can spin together.
And then the probe is mounted so
that it's pointing at the cylinder.
And in the image on the
left, you can see the light
that the probe analyzes and shines.
And from that, you can tell
that we're only ever
imaging a very small section
of the cylinder at any one time.
And while the probe is pointed
at the cylinder, it is configured
to rapidly acquire measures, about
a thousand measures per second.
And while it's acquiring, we
spin the cylinder in front of it.
And when you do that and plot
the results, you'll see something
like the animation on the right.
And what you're seeing is that
same pattern of peaks and valleys
that you saw on the previous
slide, but now there's one valley
that should be marked with a
red arrow that's oscillating up
and down as the cylinder rotates.
And to read this, remember
that the stylus sits
in the groove while
the cylinder rotates.
So this oscillation means that
as the stylus sat in that portion
of the groove and the cylinder
rotated, the needle would oscillate
up and down with that groove bottom,
so that vertical oscillation
is the audio content.
After a full rotation, the
needle would have moved
over to the next groove
onto the right.
Another thing that you'll
notice is that the peaks
and valleys are falling
together down the frame.
And this animation only shows
about a quarter of a rotation,
but you can imagine that if
we kept rotating, the peaks
and valleys might at some point
dip out the bottom of the frame.
And the reason for this is
that on the small scale
cylinders are not perfectly round,
there are ellipses and
there's also local lumps
or deformities in the wax.
And so, falling down the
screen means we're coming
down on the side on
one of those lumps.
The probe only has a finite
range that tends to be smaller
than the side of roundness,
so it's generally not possible
to allow the probe to sit statically
and still keep the cylinder
in the view over the
entire rotation.
To correct for this, we use another
instrument to measure the height
of the cylinder ahead of where
the probe is measuring and we feed
that data to a motor that moves the
camera to chase after the surface
as it rises and falls,
and this keeps the surface
in range the entire time and
this is called focus control.
And the need for focus control
is the first of many ways
in which this process
has to be tuned
to the particularity of
individual cylinders.
When everything is
working correctly,
when focus control is enabled, we
rotate through one full rotation
of the cylinder, the cylinder
stays in range the whole time.
And at the end of the rotation,
we're imaging the same point
that we were when we started.
And over the course of that
rotation, we've collected somewhere
between 20,000 and
60,000 measurements
of that 1.8 millimeter wide line.
If you save and display
the measures that you took
over that rotation next to each
other, we can create a topography
of the cylinder one ring at a time.
And what you're seeing on screen is
realtime acquisition for cylinder
with focus control and
with more active audio
and the corresponding topography
with several channels in it
that represent the groove that
the needle would have followed.
To scan an entire cylinder,
what we do is we make one
full rotation then we step
over to the portion that hasn't been
measured yet, and we rotate it again
and measure another ring, and then
step over and measure, step over
and measure and repeat all the way
down the length of the cylinder,
sweeping out these 1.8
millimeter-wide rings of images.
The number of measures that we take
around each rotation of the cylinder
at this point dictates the
sampling rate of our final audio.
One revolution of the cylinder
contains as certain duration
of audio which is set by the
recording speed of the cylinder.
So for example, if a
cylinder was recorded
at 120 rotations per minute,
each time the stylus rotated
around the cylinder it would
produce half a second of audio.
So if we collect 48,000
samples over one rotation,
then we've made 48,000 measures
over half a second of audio
which would translate to
an output sampling rate
of 96,000 samples per
second of audio.
If need be, we can sample well
in excess of what is needed
to output audio at
96,000 samples per second,
though this does increase the amount
of time it takes to do a scan.
Scanning an entire cylinder,
depending on the resolution,
takes between one and four hours.
But this process is automated,
so we can load up a cylinder,
we can set up our scan, start it
and then walk away and come back one
to four hours later to a completed
surface map containing measurements
at the height at many, many points
over the surface of a cylinder.
And this is the machine
that we built to do this
for the Phoebe Hearst
Anthropology Museum project.
You can see there is a long arm
and the cylinders rest along
that shaft supported
by plastic plugs
that rest inside the cylinders.
Previous versions of the scanning
machine only allow for loading
and scanning one cylinder at a time.
But for this project, we
expanded and built a machine
with a longer-than-usual shaft for
holding cylinders which allows us
to load a total of three at a time.
At one to three hours per cylinder,
this lets us run for typically
around nine hours without user
intervention or supervision,
which opens the possibility
of running scans overnight,
and that was the main goal and point
of innovation for this project.
Our goal was to scan
the Hearst collection
in a high-volume systematic way,
scanning three cylinders over night,
three during the day, scanning
almost constantly and pushing
out six maps of cylinders everyday.
The longer arm, the longer
shaft was a valuable change
but it proved quite
difficult to implement
because we're taking measurements
that are accurate on such
as small scale, vibrations,
deviations or imprecisions
and motions and in the physical
pieces that we work with
and built our machine with, add
imprecisions to the measurements
that we take, and those can show
up as audible effects
in the final audio.
The length of the shaft
exacerbates this problem.
Small vibrations at the bottom
of the shaft get amplified
and exaggerated over the length,
and the way that the shaft also
exaggerates during vibrations.
And ultimately, we had to try
several different configurations
over the course of the project.
In addition to reimagining how we
could physically build the system
to accommodate many cylinders,
we also had to update
our software interface.
So this is the interface that's
used to control acquisition.
The surface level, it allows the
operator to adjust parameters
to control the scan, setting what
region of the cylinder to scan,
what resolution and so forth.
And for the method in general
but especially for this project
where we're working with
cylinders in the thousands produced
in different locations,
under different conditions,
over a four-decade time span,
the scanning apparatus
must be adaptable.
The properties of cylinders
change slightly depending on when
and how they were made, and so the
scanning interface includes options
to let us optimize our data
taking for the cylinders at hand.
It also had to be updated for the
current project to be conducive
to a higher volume workflow.
At the beginning of the
project, I redesigned it.
I redesigned sections of
it to allow for scanning
at least three cylinders,
potentially each
at different parameters
without user input in-between.
And I also incorporated changes to
tune it specifically to our project,
so that museum-specific metadata
is saved along with the results
of the scan and so that operators
have access to information
about the cylinders when
they're handling them,
loading them and setting up scans.
Under the surface, the
software is also ensuring
that our measurements
are taken carefully.
Again, we're making measurements
on a very small scale,
and so just as external physical
vibrations can cause noise and data,
big jumps in the focus
motor or hiccups
in data flow can show small
changes in our measurements
that have big effects
in the final audio.
And our measurements have to
be ultimately carefully timed
so that the rate of acquisition
matches the rate of rotation
and so that-- and the focus
control has to be very incremental
and gradual and carefully done.
And the last thing to
note about acquisition is
that during this project
we've been able
to make it work for
broken cylinders.
The only real physical demand on
media is that we need to be able
to maneuver them around
and shine light on them.
So the risk with delicate media
becomes that they might fall apart
on the mandrel, or
if they're unstable,
they might wobble while
we're measuring them.
And so if cylinders are cracked or
broken, we can use special fixtures
to keep them still
and keep them intact
and fully supported while
they're spinning around.
Cracked cylinders can
be held together
to prevent further splitting
with polyethylene bands
wrapped around the cylinder.
Broken cylinders can be
reassembled like jigsaw puzzles
on a cylindrical form and held
in place using those same
polyethylene bands and in the areas
that don't have audio on
them with sticky putty.
Then both cracked and broken
cylinders can be scanned as usual,
we just scan up to the tape
then we move it into the portion
that was already imaged
and we move over
and scan the rest of the cylinder.
And so when everything works
together correctly, the end result
of a full cylinder scan
are two groups of files.
We get metadata files that
describe the scanning process
that get achieved and then
we get our main output file.
And what that is, is it's usually
between one and two gigabytes
and it's just an ordered
list of height values
at several million points
around the cylinder.
And we call this our surface map.
The question then becomes, what
do we do with it to make it useful
and to make sense of
it in a meaningful way?
And an obvious solution is
to visualize it in some way,
but there are many
options, animations,
topographies, charts, et cetera.
But what we want out of
this data is very specific.
We care very specifically about
what's happening in the groove,
how its height is changing.
So we want to choose a method
of visualizing our data
in which the groove
bottom is clearly
and obviously distinguishable.
So the images that we produce and
work with are grayscale depth images
like the one on the right.
Moving vertically in the
image corresponds to moving
around the circumference
of the cylinder
which is the first
dimension, moving horizontally
in the image corresponds to moving
down the length of the cylinder
which is our second dimension,
and the color conveys the third
dimension which is the height.
Blacker tones indicate a lower point
on the surface, and lighter tones,
closer to white, indicate
higher points on the surface.
And so in this view, we're looking
at the cylinders if I cut a seam
down the wall of the cylinder from
the bottom to top and then open it
up and flattened it
out on my screen.
And so again in this view, white
is higher and dark is lower.
So the groove bottom
is now very obvious
as these dark vertical
stripes down our screen.
And when read in this convention,
patterns in large data sets are
easily recognizable visually
to operators and computationally
to image-processing methods.
And just as important deviations
from those patterns which can come
from errors in acquisition or
anomalies in a specific cylinder due
to the recording conditions
under which it was made,
these things become
clearly visible as well.
So to actually produce sound
from a completed surface map,
the data is loaded into a
piece of in-house software
that stitches the data together,
displays the depth image
that users can look
through in detail,
and what you're seeing
here is a screenshot
of the analysis software
that we use.
Parameters at the top
tune various algorithms
to the particular cylinder at hand.
Again, making sure that
the process is suitable
for a wide variety of cylinders.
The main image on the upper
portion of the window shows six
of those 1.8 millimeter wide bands
or rings which is six rotations
around with the cylinder that are
all stacked up next to each other.
And the relevant data
is very clear to--
visually to operators but it needs
to be analytically isolated
by a computer program.
And because the data is so regular,
because we have this regular
consistent pattern of black stripes
across the image, we can use a
combination of minimal finding
and pattern recognition algorithms
to go through the data set
and identify the bottom of the
groove and mark it with a blue line.
And you can in the upper
black and white image
where the software has
gone through and done that.
And so we call this process
of identifying flagging
the groove bottom tracking.
The right-hand side of the
image shows a zoomed in view
of a small section of the
larger cylinder image.
And if you follow along the bottom
of the groove which I've marked
with a red line, you can see
the image oscillating from light
to dark, which in this
image corresponds
to the groove height
oscillating up and down.
And again the vertical
change from high to low,
high to low is audio content.
The plot at the bottom middle
of the interface shows a point
by point plot of the data
along the thick red line
which is really a point by
point reconstruction of the path
that a playback stylus
would have traced
out as it moves through the groove.
And this is also the data that
the tracking algorithm isolated
from the rest of the image by going
through and flagging the bottom
of the groove with the blue line.
And so this path is very,
very close to being all
of the necessary information needed
to reproduce the sound
on the recording.
The final step is to actually take
the derivative along that line
and calculate the speed of the
stylus because for these recordings,
due to the mechanics of
the recording device,
the speed of the needle is
proportional to the pressure
of the sound waves, and so
the speed is what's identical
to the sound signal that
we're trying to recover.
And this analysis works for broken
cylinders too with the added benefit
of providing an image of the break
so that we can tell
how severe it is.
In the best case scenario, if the
break is small and the grooves line
up on either side of the division,
we can process the
cylinder normally.
The only complication becomes
if the split is too large
or if pieces aren't
lined up correctly.
Sometimes the tracking algorithm
can't find the path of the stylus,
it gets lost across the
boundaries between pieces,
and the program needs
user intervention
to trace along the
bottom of the groove.
And so, we can still work
with these broken cylinders
where the data doesn't quite line
up, it just ends up being labor
and time intensive for the user.
So I have here a sample of a
recording from the collection
that we digitized during
this project, it records Ishi
who was the last surviving member
of a group called the Yahi.
He encountered a UC
anthropologist who did a series
around 200 recordings with him all
in the Hearst Museum collection.
And this clip is a short
excerpt, it's 20 seconds,
but a full recording would
typically be around two
and half minutes at most.
And first, you're going
to hear a voice in English
and that's Alfred Kroeber who
would have conducted the recording
session, and then he'll
introduce the recording
and then you'll hear Ishi singing.
And then also on screen,
you'll be able
to see the cursor retracing the path
that the original stylus
would have taken.
>> Alfred Kroeber: [Background
Noise] April 14, 1940.
Ishi, justice song,
repetition of 1714.
[ Noise and Singing ]
>> Olivia Dill: So there
is a few things to notice.
The first is these
clicking and pooping noises,
and those are results of dust
or dirt on top of the cylinder
of small scratches
digging into the cylinder.
And each time the stylus
encounters it,
it pops up and creates that sound.
And then also towards the end,
there's this more regular
rhythmic crunching noise,
and that's the result of the needle
encountering patches of mold decay,
places where mold has
eaten away part of the wax.
And it turns out that because
we're working with images
and because we can look at
the surface in such detail,
we're actually in a position
to minimize the audible
effects of those defects.
We can isolate them from the
intentionally recorded audio.
Looking at the left, most
image you'll see raw data
and there's a big white
smear across the bottom.
And because white is high,
again that represents
something that's sitting
on top of the cylinder.
So that's probably a hair
or some other type of fiber.
And if you look at the point at the
plot underneath the leftmost image,
you can see that there's
this slowly undulating curve,
and that's the path that
the needle would have taken.
And then towards the end, there's
a sudden very large jump in height
and that's the boundary of the hair.
And that sudden jump in height,
as the stylus went over it,
it would cause the stylus to pop up
and that would introduce very
high frequency audio in the form
of those pops and clicks
that you're hearing.
And so what we do is we use an
edge-finding algorithm to go
through the images and flag changes
that are too steep to be audio
as the boundaries blemishes
or blobs.
And in the middle view,
you can see all the defects
that the algorithm found
encircled in orange.
And on the rightmost image, you can
see where the algorithm has smoothed
between the found boundaries and
clean the defects from the image
to lessen their impact on the audio.
So I'm going to play you a
smaller section from the audio
that you've just heard and
then I'll play it again for you
without cleaning, just the raw data
and then I'll play
you the clean version
so that you have a
point of comparison.
So here's the raw data.
[ Singing ]
And then here it is with
the cleaning applied.
[ Singing ]
So, some improvement.
Another thing to notice is this
high frequency hissing noise
in the background of the audio, and
that's actually a signature product
of the method that we're using.
Because we're digitalizing with
light, which is far smaller
than a traditional playback
stylus, we see the surface
in far greater resolution
than a needle would have.
The spot size of the probe is
several microns whereas a stylus
would be a few hundred microns wide.
And this difference in scale,
that's the optical scans resolve far
smaller and closer together changes
in the surface height
which correspond
to much higher frequency noises
than a stylus can register.
So, in the diagram at the top,
you're seeing the different colored
waving lines that represent signals
at different frequencies
and wavelengths.
And the line at the top
would have large wavelengths
and to low frequencies and
the frequency increases
as you step down in those lines.
The stylus can only physically
conform to the largest wavelengths
where the spot of the probe
has no problem resolving
and measuring very high frequency
signals all the way down.
And so this means that the optical
method produces flat transfers.
We digitize higher frequency audio.
We can resolve and-- And as a result
of the resolution that we have,
we can resolve and identify and
clean out those sudden changes
in height caused by damage as I
just showed you, but it also means
that we digitize higher
frequency noise.
A lot of that content occurs outside
the audible range of hearing,
but some of that is the
high frequency hiss present
in the raw audio from our system.
And it's a trivial matter to filter
out any extra high-frequency noise
with commercial audio software.
And for the current
version of our project,
we provide a filtered version that's
a little easier to listen to with
that extra high-frequency
noise filtered out in addition
to the raw version for all the
cylinders in the collection.
And so at the end of analysis with
our software, we get a two-minute
or so long digital audio file,
and the way that we got there was
by chasing relevant information
through these different formats.
There was some initial sound
wave and then we traced
that into the height of the-- to
the height of the cylinder surface,
and then into these black
and white depth images,
and finally into this
digital audio file.
From a physicist's perspective,
we started out with some
original real-world signal,
and we recovered it and we digitized
it, and that's sort of the boundary
of what the physics
toolkit is equipped to do.
But there's still this final area
of information that gets left
out of this equation,
which is the information
that really motivated all of
this effort in the first place,
and that's the cultural and
linguistic information derived
by analysis from linguists
and from community members.
And so the last piece of
this process, the last piece
of the puzzle is to turn over
the audio file to those people.
For the Hearst Museum project,
our final audio is handled
by the California Language Archive
which is an online repository
of indigenous language materials.
They will facilitate
restricted access to the content
of the Hearst Museum cylinders.
So, as the technology stands now,
we're capable of doing quite a lot.
We can create carefully-acquired
high-resolution surface maps
accurate on the micron scale.
We can analyze those maps to
extract audio, we can clean them
to minimize the audible
effect of decay and damage,
and we can create primary
digitized--
primary digital files to be
circulated and meta to be--
metadata to be archived
which ensures
that the maps will make sense to
those looking at them in the future,
and will allow those
maps to be reanalyzed
as new processing algorithms
become available.
And as of this current project,
we can do this in large volumes
for media in various
states of stability.
But, I'd like to mention some
questions that we can ask
about the future direction of the
technology now that we're working
on a larger scale allowed
by the new project.
One of the lessons that start to--
that started to emerge out of this
project is potential different ways
that we could be working
with broken cylinders.
Currently, the strategy
is to reassemble them
and analyze them as
if they were whole.
At the top, you're seeing
a cylinder that was broken
into five large pieces
that we reassembled
on the cylindrical
form and then scanned.
And for the most part, this jigsaw
puzzle strategy works fairly well.
But as I said earlier,
if we're inaccurate,
and for us inaccurate means not
precise on the micron scale,
which is highly probable,
if we're inaccurate
when we reassemble the cylinders,
then the groove might not line
up across the transition
between pieces.
The tracking algorithm
has a tendency to jump
to a different portion of
the groove after the break,
connecting two pieces of
the cylinder that aren't--
that weren't meant to be connected.
So then when we play it back,
the broken cylinders were
modeling the motion of the stylus
as if it's jumping around
the cylinder and the audio
that we produced is jumbled
and in the wrong order.
This problem has been studied
in the past for broken disks,
but now we have an opportunity to
look at examples of broken cylinders
and potentially make
improvements to our method.
There are a few different
strategies we could take.
We could continue scanning the
cylinders the way that we do now
and introduce new tracking
algorithms
to better track the broken
pieces or to rearrange the data
after it's been taken, and
that would use capabilities
that we already have in
our software in a way.
Or another solution
that's very appealing
to us though more computationally
intensive is
to take a step backwards
and address the problem
from the acquisition stage.
If we scan the cylinder in pieces,
which would take the creation
of a new fixture to hold
fragments in place under the probe,
then we could get several
images of fragments,
and those images would have
very well-defined borders.
And then we could transport the
jigsaw puzzle assembly problem
that we do physically with the
cylinders now into the digital space
and reassemble the pieces digitally.
With a new more sophisticated
user interface,
we could either allow the
user to move the pieces around
and assemble them themselves,
or in a more complex
data analysis solution,
we could analyze the images
of fragments, define the edges
and process the geometry
of the edges to suggest
and align likely matches.
If we do this correctly
enough and if pieces get lined
up precisely enough,
then we wouldn't have
to change our tracking algorithm,
the existing algorithm
should work properly.
And, also the amount of handling
of artifacts would be
decreased in this case.
And in the case where
the matching is carried
out computationally
rather than by a user,
we would have a more robust way
of working with media in many,
many pieces, which
is actually something
that we're not currently
equipped to digitize.
This issue of increasing our ability
to handle broken cylinders is one
that we're eager to explore as a lot
of the intrigue behind the
collection and many of the requests
that we've gotten are for broken
cylinders as those are the ones
that the most people
have not heard yet.
And also these broken cylinders are
the most time intensive cylinders
that we work with.
Under the current method, a broken
cylinder can take as much as twice
as long as an intact
cylinder to scan and triple
if not quadruple as long to process.
Something else that we've
learned and continue to learn
about is duplicate cylinders.
When we started the
project we learned
that then anthropology
museum collection contains
around 300 cylinders, so that's less
than 10% of the total collection
that have been duplicated
in some way.
Some cylinders have anywhere between
one and three separate duplicates
that are labeled physically
by engravings around the top
of the cylinder and
in museum metadata
as being duplicates in some way.
Physically, cylinder duplicates are
often very similar but they appear
to be made out of different
kinds of wax
with different surface
textures both visibly
and on the microscopic scale.
We've also seen several of
these duplicate cylinders
with a chalky finish that we don't
typically see in the originals.
And we've had to learn how to
process and scan these effectively
as they're often more
difficult to work with.
So we're collecting data
and we're learning more
about the physical differences
between original cylinders
and their duplicates.
And what we are not sure
of is exactly how those
duplicates were made.
There are several potential
processes,
the first being the creation of
a mold of the original cylinder
and then using that mold to
cast or print off duplicates,
and some duplicates that we've
seen are certainly very similar
to their originals.
In cases where there are multiple
duplicates we've seen duplicates
that have identical features
on the microscopic scale,
which does suggest some sort of
printing from a cast or mold.
But the process that we're aware
of for creating duplicates using
casts destroys the originals
which ask the question how we
can have supposed duplicates
and originals paired together.
Also, not all duplicates
are visually similar.
Some duplicate original pairs differ
drastically in the microscopic view.
With the amplitude of audio
oscillation, groove width
and groove depth changing
drastically
between the two artifacts,
oftentimes the audio
on cylinder will sound
audibly faster than the audio
on another cylinder even when
played back at the same speed.
This would suggest that either a
method of acoustic transfer perhaps
by playing a cylinder--
playing an original cylinder
and directing the audio from the
horn on one phonograph into the horn
on another or a pantographic
method, driving the stylus
on one recording device
with a stylus on another.
And so as it stands now,
we're still in the process
of gathering visual evidence as we
scan more duplicate original sets.
But potentially this data could
direct us to a meaningful conclusion
about the provenance of
these duplicated cylinders.
Something else that we've
observed while collecting
and processing data are
interesting anomalies.
The vast majority of cylinder
data looks very, very similar.
For an entire cylinder, typically
you just see vertical stripes--
vertical black stripes that
are all about the same width
and same distance apart
within a cylinder
and typically also the same depth
throughout the entire cylinder.
But this consistency within
and between data sets means
that when there are breaks on this
regularity, they really stand out.
And so as we go through the
collection, we see many instances
of irregular groove patterns.
We've seen several cylinders
where the stylus is
wandering unconstrained
across the surface potentially
resulting from a defect
in the lead screw mechanism
on recording devices
that controls the position of
the needle along the length
of the cylinder as it spins.
We've also seen repeating patterns
as if the cylinder
was recorded twice
or as if there was
some other malfunction
in the recording apparatus
or stylus.
And part of the development of
this project has been learning how
to effectively process and
work through these anomalies
which can be difficult
as our automatic groove
finding algorithm works best
for regular consistent patterns.
Sometimes, we've had the opportunity
to correct these anomalies.
In the case of this cylinder
where there are two sets
of groove patterns on top
of each other, I went in
and I manually told the software
first to follow one pattern and then
to follow the second pattern.
And I produced two separate
audio files resulting
from the two separate cylinder
paths, and then listen back
and chose for the final product
the audio that made sense
and wasn't jumbled
in the wrong order.
We also see and note a
typical surface textures
and interesting patterns of decay.
There are certain shapes
that we're used to seeing.
Mold decay, cracks, divots from
fingernails and scratches are common
and have very distinct shapes and
identifiable visual signatures.
But we've also come across some
new shapes and morphologies
that we haven't seen before.
Some of these are evidence of damage
for which the cause
is still unknown.
And others are causes
that we now understand.
For example, through discussion
with our project conservator,
we found that the decay pattern
on the bottom right occurred
in regions first on
a cylinder that had--
at one point had adhesive tape
wrapped around the cylinder
and then removed, and so that's
the result of that process.
And so now, we know the visual
signature of this process
and we are able to recognize
it in other cylinders
that we've scanned since.
Another pattern that
we've seen recurring
through the collection is a high
frequency very small vertical
oscillation at much higher
frequencies than audio occurs,
and at much higher frequencies than
are registered by a playback stylus.
And so in the plot on the bottom,
you're seeing that vertical
oscillation as hair or fuzz sort
of on top of that very
slow angulating curve
that the stylus would have
traced to produce audio.
We suspect that this high-frequency
oscillation is an effect
from the cutter vibrating
or chattering very rapidly
against the cylinder's
surface as the cylinder is cut.
And we further suspect
that the frequency
at which this chatter
occurs should be dictated
by the resonant frequency specific
to the dimensions of the stylus
and the mechanics of
the recording device.
If this is true it should be
possible to use the frequency
of this shudder as measured on the
cylinder as a reference tone to use
to predict the recording
speed of the cylinder.
And this would be useful as
we've seen several cylinders
with either no documented
playback speed
or with an incorrect
documented playback speed.
So I'm looking through these
last few examples of things
that we've learned and hoped to
learn by analyzing the images.
The impact of our project
has the potential
to go beyond creating our repository
of sought-after culturally
and academically significant audio.
The method, as I've described
today, is very targeted.
We collect our images and we
extract specifically the position
of the groove bottom and both
the path of the playback stylus
and the position of
defects that affect it,
and we use those things
specifically to produce sound.
But what this overview
or what this imagining
of the process overlooks is that we
collect incredibly detailed images
of the entire surface
of these cylinders.
And so as a result of that,
we are able to observe things
like what I've just mentioned.
Anomalies in the groove pattern,
the evidence of malfunctions
in the machinery, the microscopic
state of these materials,
interesting dynamic interactions
between the recording stylus
and the wax surface, and
many other curiosities
that aren't evident playing these
recordings back with the stylus.
Even just observing these
curiosities and following
up on anomalies as they come up
while they're processing the images
with the goal of producing
sound has given us information
and we have learned more
about our collection.
As of this current project,
we are collecting these
images in the hundreds.
And by the end of the project,
we'll have a repository
of thousands of them.
And so it's exciting and
enticing to imagine what kinds
of questions can be
asked and answered
through even more careful analytics
study of a database of these images,
a database with more entries
than we've been able
to accumulate before.
Those with a data analysis toolkit
would be very well-positioned
to answer compelling questions
across many disciplines
by analyzing these images in
just as targeted ways as we have
but with different targets in mind.
And we hope that there's more
to learn for those with interest
in a wide variety of fields,
information about our collection's
history, about the processes
of recording cylinders and
about the practicalities
of preserving the materials.
So to close, I'd like to say
thank you to the many institutions
and people who have
given funding and support
to the optical scanning
technology in the decade
since its creation and
before this project.
And finally, I'd like
to point out that
over 40 students have
contributed to the development
of the optical scanning technology
outside of the current project
since its initial publication.
Undergraduates on campus work with
the technology every semester.
We're in the process of
training an undergraduate
to work in our lab right now.
And students from the University of
Applied Sciences developed portions
of the acquisition and analysis
software as parts of month longs--
months long master's
thesis every summer.
And so-- And also I myself
started working with the technology
when I was still a student.
So we hope that there's
opportunities for students
at the undergraduate and at
the graduate level in addition
to scholars to engage
with the questions
that I've proposed here and beyond.
So thank you very much for your time
and for your attention
and for having me here.
If you're still curious
there are some links here.
And if you have any questions,
I'll do my best to answer.
[ Applause ]
>> Fenella France: Do we
have any questions for Oliva,
and we'll repeat those
questions for our remote viewers.
>> You mentioned that the
servers have data on the speed
on which they're recorded,
how often do you find that,
do you see much variation-- i.e. the
original recording [inaudible] was
spring loaded?
Do you see variations or like decay
in the [inaudible]
speed in the cylinder?
>> Olivia Dill: So the question
was about the accuracy of the RP--
of the speed data that we have and
any variations that we've seen.
So there's two kind
of pieces to that.
We get our data from-- there was
a massive survey of the collection
that was done a while ago by Richard
Keeling and he wrote up a catalogue
that has all of the
RPMs listed in it.
And so far, we found three out
of 500-some cylinders for which
that speed, when we played them
back, it was obviously wrong.
So sometimes they are inaccurate.
And then the other
thing is that sometimes
within the individual
cylinder there will be sections
where you can audibly hear
the cylinder coming up to
that recording speed, so it will--
it makes it like zipper
sound as it comes from a high
to low frequency and levels out.
So, there is some variation within
the individual cylinder about that.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Yeah. There were a few
where there were many,
many of those speed changes,
but again that's like,
maybe five in 500.
>> Did I understand correctly?
Probably didn't which
is why I am asking.
Was your digital image
output actually more accurate
than the original recording?
And if so could that be
corrected with something later
down the road once all
of these are scanned
with some type of 3D
printing device?
>> Olivia Dill: So the question
was if our method is more accurate
than the actual playback
of the cylinder and if
that could be corrected
with 3D printing.
It's less a matter of accurate and
more a matter of-- I think you're--
are you referring to the frequency
domain that I talked about?
It's--
>> If that makes sense,
that's what I'm referring to.
>> Olivia Dill: So it
just ends up being that--
a playback stylus can only play back
up to a certain frequency of audio.
And then after that frequency,
if there is anything there,
it gets attenuated
and the volume drops.
And that happens typically
around like 4000 hertz.
And the recording capabilities
of the devices
in the first place only
went up to about 5000 hertz.
So there's that 1000 hertz sweet
spot where we're catching audio
that can't be played
back with a stylus.
So in that regard, we are
getting more information
than you can have by
playing them back.
But in terms of if we are
creating information that's not
in the cylinder, I-- my tendency
is to say that that's not the case.
Yeah, I hope that helps.
>> I have a two-part question.
How does this technology compare to
other kinds of technology that work
with cylinders to reproduce
sounds, and will you be--
is this technology can
be taken on the road,
what's the adaptability
and scalability?
>> Olivia Dill: OK.
So the question was about how our
method compares to existing methods
of transfer and if ours
is scalable and movable.
So there are-- the other
I think common method
of digitizing these
things is the archeophone.
And so again, there is that
1000 or so hertz bandwidth
of frequency range that we can
recover that that device cannot.
It just ends up being a question
of whether or not there's anything
that you want to recover.
But the information
from our system up above
in that high-frequency range,
even if it's not recovering
vocal content,
it is recovering the content that
allows us to do our blob cleaning
and to see these high-frequency
effects.
So, that's kind of where our system
differs from those existing systems.
And as far as transportability,
it's-- I mean once we built it,
it's pretty much-- we could
take it apart and rebuild it
and move it, it would be difficult.
There's also a little bit of
particularity in where we place it.
Currently, I work in a basement
and we like that because, again,
vibrations leach into system.
And so if you're up on the
sixth floor of a building--
we do have another version of
this that's up on the sixth floor
of a building-- and the
building itself wobbles,
and so that's something
that they have to account
for in their measurements.
So, there's that factor
about where you put it.
It is difficult and it does require
precision to build and to maintain,
so there's that sort of
skill set investment as well.
But in scalability,
I think this is--
that's kind of what we're trying
to figure out in this process is
if we can scale it to make it
larger and make it more applicable
for production and
systematic scanning.
Does that help?
>> I'm just curious how
you do the image stitching
with the different
[inaudible] section
and like how much overlap you have
to have between two adjacent spots
to get like an accurate
idea of how to [inaudible].
>> Olivia Dill: Yeah, so--
that's actually interesting.
The question was about stitching
and how we compile--
separate scans, correct?
So, it typically takes about four
millimeters of overlap is my cutoff
between the first and
the second image.
And the interesting thing
is we don't actually do
that stitching together
visually with the image,
we produce two separate audio files
and then we use commercial
audio processing software
to find the identical point
between those audio files
and then we basically just cut
and paste and stick them together.
And it's kind of a comfort that they
usually end up being identical even
if the scan is done
a little bit later.
There is at some point in the audio
from both sections that's visibly
identical at the waveform level.
>> What's maximum length of time in
realtime is taken each one cylinder?
>> Olivia Dill: So the
maximum length of time--
[ Inaudible Discussion ]
Oh that's true.
>> Make it both--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Olivia Dill: I think, maximum
I've seen is about six hours
and that was a very high resolution
and very high exposure time,
but that's way beyond
sort of the threshold
and I've seen broken cylinders
that the scanning process took
maybe an hour but the actual process
of me trying to physically
manipulate it and get it
to stay still while it was
being measured took eight hours.
But that's probably my
fault not the software's.
>> More from an aesthetic
standpoint,
since this was before the time
when recording engineers
was really even a thing.
Do you find a lot of variability in
the quality of the recordings or,
like, you know, the audibility?
>> Olivia Dill: So the
question was about variability
and differences in quality.
It does vary a lot.
A big factor is how well the
cylinder has been preserved,
the cylinder that's had a lot
of mold damage sounds
are very, very bad.
So that's kind of the biggest
most immediate factor for me
as somebody listening back.
But in terms of what
was originally there,
there is a lot of variability.
Something that we see a lot is,
if the audio that's being
recorded is too loud then we see--
the stylus needs to
trace out a very steep
and very tall vertical oscillation,
and sometimes the height
of that oscillation is higher
than the surface of the cylinder,
so you see that the needle pops
out the top of the cylinder
to every upswing and then
comes back down sometime later
and that's called clipping.
And so that's a big, very clearly
ineffective how the cylinder was
recorded, how close the
person was to the horn,
how loud they were speaking
and if they've been instructed
to record properly,
so we see that a lot.
And that's the biggest thing I
have noticed, is just volume,
how clear they're speaking.
If the stylus-- Again, sometimes
you see these recording anomalies
where it's clear but something
was off in the recording.
Something was broken or somebody
wasn't handling it carefully,
so that will affect your output.
Yeah, that's about all I've seen.
>> For those who may be new to
this, I mean including myself, but--
who may have access to a large
collection of wax cylinders
and they really don't know how to
prioritize which ones to submit
to an organization such
as yourself, you know,
once we get more [inaudible].
Can you give any clues like,
OK look for the yellow ones--
they're going to degrade
faster, any clues like that?
>> Olivia Dill: The question
was about prioritizing
which cylinders we digitize.
I don't know from a
preservation standpoint
if there are certain types of
cylinders that are more vulnerable
to decay than other ones.
>> Fenella France: We will
be having a talk on some
of the work we've been looking
at with different cylinders
in the nearish future and we'll be
sharing some of our latest research.
So, look for this in the
next two or three months.
>> Olivia Dill: Yeah,
the one thing I can say
from our project perspective is
our priority list so far has come
from the community, from the
cylinders that are the most sought
after from patrons that want to
hear things and also from our own--
we have-- one of the PIs is a
linguist who studies these material
and so from his linguistic
and academic priorities.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
So there were some-- There were
two that we were able to very,
very slightly improve
by cleaning them.
But, even in those cases, it
looked-- the scans that resulted,
the surface was just so uneven and
so noisy that we couldn't even--
there were two that we just
couldn't find grooves on.
And so it was some-- we
think it was some property
of the surface that
it was just uneven.
I'm not-- Yeah, we haven't
figured that out yet.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Yeah, one more because that
someone asked if you expand
on the frequency limit of styli,
because there are sound systems
that are capable of
reproducing beyond 4000 hertz,
so is there a stylus
contractor for that sweet spot?
>> Olivia Dill: Yeah, I'm not sure--
I know there are stylus
that can go higher
but the tradeoff there I believe is
that those stylus have
a smaller surface area
and so they apply more pressure
to the surface of the cylinder
which is, from a preservation
standard,
not desirable because that's
more degradation on the surface.
So, yes it is possible to go higher
than that sort of 4000 cutoff,
but again, at the risk of
damaging your cylinder surface.
And we did do some studies over
the summer to see exactly what
that tradeoff is but we have
yet to really assess that out.
>> Fenella France: Just
one quick question.
>> You said that there are
some direct transfers that take
from earlier days, how does this
compare to sounds [inaudible]?
>> Olivia Dill: Yeah, the question
was about comparing our results
to tape transfers,
and we have compared
and there are a couple different
things that are going on,
there are some effects that happen
from the EQ that was applied
by the people doing those transfers,
and they have some
high-frequency artifact and a very,
very loud low frequency
noise envelope.
So it just-- it sounds like
there's this big booming furnace
in the background and we
don't have that in our audio.
But in the audible
range, it's very similar.
It just ends up being that ours have
the click and the cleaning effect,
so ours are cleaner, they have
less clicks, and in the cases
of mold damage that
makes a big different.
And then ours is a flat transfer
so there's no overall EQ,
there's no amplifying
low frequencies
or attenuating high frequencies.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Olivia Dill: I do
not know the method
for direct transfer I just know
that it was from a hard stylus.
[ Inaudible Discussion ]
>> Fenella France: So, I think
what's really fascinating is--
and one thing we've been
talking about with [inaudible] is
that the amount of data we
can keep to actually analyze
from scholar's perspective
as you are starting
to say is really quite
stunning and this sort of trends
that we're finding once
you get this huge database
which I think is really
exciting for the future.
We'll be here for just a few more
moments before Olivia has to rush
for a plane but can you please
join me in thanking her again
for a wonderful presentation.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.